oui j'ai bien compris votre question est
bien là mon sens ce qui caractérise ce
temps et quand je dis ce temps c'est le
contenu spatiale du concept temps qui
bien sûr m'intéresse ce qui caractérise
donc à mon avis ce temps ce qui est ce
que j'appellerais son image définition
et vous remarquerez au passage que dans
des finitions il y à des fi etc images
qu'on tient à
c'est la conjonction des pulsions et des
possibles quitte l eau trop chauffer
dans la bassine fait imploser exploser
le couvercle dialectique de l'échaudé
idéologie balayant d'un seul coup d'un
seul grâce aux carburants désir le jeu
le mois et le ca pour atteindre enfin la
seule finalité de l'homme nouveau la
clarté